cái mũi vắc Xin nào là những cái mũi vắc Xin
quan trọng bắt buộc phải tiêm Cho em bé nhà mình
và những cái mũi nào là cái mũi
ờ không quan trọng không cần phải tiêm
thì thật Ra đối với vắc Xin ấy
nếu có thể tiêm được là tốt nha bởi vì
1đ bỏ Ra để tiêm vắc Xin ấy nó sẽ bằng 7 cái đồng mà mình điều trị.
chưa nói đến những cái loại vắc Xin mà đôi khi có như vậy ví dụ
ví dụ như là cái con não mô cầu ấy
thật Ra nó tỉ lệ mắc ở trong cộng đồng nó rất là thấp
nhưng mà một khi đã mắc
trong vòng 24 giờ nó có thể làm cái biến chứng bị mù lòa hoặc là bại liệt
hay là ví dụ như là vắc Xin à ví dụ như là cái a
quai bị nó có thể làm bị vô sinh
thế nên là à những cái loại nào
bây giờ mà để hỏi là những cái loại mà bắt buộc cần phải
tiêm ấy thì là những cái loại ở
trong cái chương trình tiêm chủng ở rộng
bao gồm là Lao này viêm gan B này
năm trong một hoặc là 6 trong một đối với dịch vụ nhá
thế rồi bạch hầu ho gà uốn ván
bại liệt sởi quai bị rubela
não Nhật Bản hoặc là bại liệt tách riêng bây giờ có thêm Rota và.
HPV đấy là những cái mũi bắt buộc nha
thế nhưng mà có một cái mũi nó không nằm ở trong cái chương trình nhiệm vụ
tiêm chủng mở rộng nhưng mà mình nghĩ là cũng nên
nên tiêm đó là phế cầu bởi vì cái phế cầu nó
rất là gây bệnh nặng ở cái phổ cái đường hô hấp của em bé và trong khi đó
khi mà em bé nó hết 6 tháng đầu đời ấy là cái hết hết cái
miễn dịch của mẹ Cho á thì là rất là dễ mắc bệnh về hô hấp mà một khi
nhiễm phế cầu ấy thì nó bị nặng lên rất nhiều.
thế rồi những cái mũi nào là cái mũi mà không bắt buộc
à mình có thể là nên tiêm nếu như mình có điều kiện
đấy là mũi cúm này
cúm đối với những cái người có bệnh nền hoặc là đối với những em bé như thế này
à thì mình nên tiêm cúm mà bị suyễn này
rồi là người già
rồi là trẻ em dưới 2 tuổi thì nên cân nhắc tiêm cúm
rồi là thủy đậu
cũng nên thủy đậu người ta hay gọi là cháy dạ ấy
à rồi là não mô cầu cũng nên nha đấy
không tiêm ở trong chương trình kiểm
tiêm trùng mở rộng mà các bà tiêm dịch vụ ấy
thì cái hvv này cũng là cái nên tiêm
bởi vì SAO bây giờ bọn.
trẻ con nó kiểu nó mới dậy thì ấy
nó của hồi từ giờ rất là sớm mà trong khi đó nó chưa kịp
bố mẹ chưa kịp trang bị Cho nó những cái kiến thức về
ờ phòng chống những cái đấy mà
thì các bà nên tôi dịch vụ cái HPV này Cho con gái nha
à thế rồi những cái gì mà nó xa hơn mà nó có
thể là nó ít quan trọng hơn so với những cái Kia
thì ví dụ như là xương Hàn hoặc là viêm gan a.